yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing BC 1956 and color we let's see
we get an absolute the main line it
seems it so what you get most frequently
you don't play my faithful a4 is rare
this particular moment I'm not try to
refute it probably not possible
let's see it's a bit it's a bit
different to my usual setup with this
nights is 698 that it's not on okay d5
eeeh
yeah I know I know that it's best to
place your form but I have so much
experience in those close positions that
I'm happy with with this I wonder I
wonder if I can actually do this it's a
bit a bit odd
preparing 98 okay yeah this is normally
very okay for me trade of trade of rooks
who came so the Queen side is closed
somewhat I got the iPhone 23 okay I'm
not sure what this is all about
hmm okay okay seven is not covered okay
let's prepare the night move then hmm
and you can actually make an argument in
favor of this one let's do it
if he goes back which would be
strategically right I can still play g6
and play 97 and the bishop trades is
quite clearly fine getting rid of the
dark squared Bishop is quite desirable
and I've got 90 for them so we should be
three looks very normal okay
that's kind of difficult to comprehend
what's the thing G forward
anyway I'm I know what I want to do my
setup with F six and so on
okay that was the idea you know what now
I understand
didn't take that into account
I wrote a five and twenty seven as a bit
it was a bit better yeah okay let's it
was a bit of a silly temple lost but the
temple is in fact not dead relevant him
[Music]
I'm not unhappy about this this whole
really okay
he's just weakening his pawn structure
and that's good I mean good for me
it's surprising can we wind upon
straight away on a four-night should go
to b6 yeah you know it's probably
probably correct and then we can then
Knight b6 Bishop d7 now how does he
cover it again he can only cover it
again with the night how is the night
ever getting there I don't know yeah
then I'm just winning this pawn how does
he coverage not b6 Bishop d7 I take it
okay for was strange
oh do I want to take or am I somewhat
vulnerable there on the dark squares I
don't know maybe I am I mean it's it's
not no problem I can just send him back
I have a winning plan I just pick up a
form
he's probably trying some counter check
there on the kingside would hear it here
it comes right okay if I get the King on
to f7 there's nothing really happening a
Kim F takes F takes the knight is
hanging could have taken maybe but I
can't just grab a form that is a good
way to do it so if I take b3 now Queen
takes yeah that's good with the tempo
against the night maybe Queen g3 is what
he wants to do
I'm king of seven you know care seven
should be okay I can also check here and
then King edge - is there something I
don't don't really have a good reply
against that if I go King of seven he's
probably going Queen g-form
it is still somewhat dangerous really
huh
hmm that's a it's really bad
I didn't didn't really see it how
problematic this is dammit that's oh
thats it's really really annoying I
could have easily delayed the capture
you know it wasn't absolutely not
necessary to take a four immediately as
I did
yeah this is probably just lost bishop
chicks these six or something and I was
it was just like a completely winning
position you just have to check for that
last bit of count to play that the
opponent has which I didn't might be
that I'm so winning here you cannot stop
the pawn it's kind of funny Jim it was
weird
now I mean I'm unhappy because it was a
strategically nicely played game and
yeah I mean I don't know where to start
exactly it was kind of not much going on
until he played rook a 4 which is just
blunder basically I take and now I have
clearly the better chances stay for
Polish this week and I I did okay at
first but then I captured at the wrong
moment okay here I can take that is of
course an alternative but f6 it's not
bad I'm happy with this f4 okay maybe
maybe here yeah I am I can I can do more
yeah the engine also wants to take so
that it's not bad
take take take and here oh yeah I have
Queen a1 which is that it's very simple
this is this is this a forced
resignation actually just basically okay
and now Bishop f8 is still a huge
advantage and even even even this is
even king of seven is an advantage at
least at this calculation depth
it seems that according to the carafe I
was never lost which is kind of
surprising
yeah bishop if I'd yeah I looked at that
but I thought that isn't helping me yeah
but he doesn't have much yeah I can take
and now it's still going to be a bit
tricky in a practical game but it seems
to the committee winning okay I went
here twin G form Keaney aides the only
Museum
Jim Queen is six and now Knight takes e4
is supposed to be still winning at least
again at the depth that the engine is
having here it's not something that I
would be totally confident about now
seems that this wins
let's it looks very dangerous Bishop g5
Queen d8 seems to win and you know yeah
okay I mean there is nothing here here
here that's this and I'm basically
crawling away here and debated that the
issue is that like even yeah I've got to
be pawn and that seems to win these
pieces are just so utterly misplaced
that I'm winning with this bloody pawn
it's funny I came I went here now Knight
a3 is draw it seems okay nobody is going
to figure that out I mean taking what he
did seemed a bit slow it he'll be three
wins yeah I just I had no time I took on
C form
and here yes he has a draw in hand with
97 bt 96 and then it's a draw with 97
Wow dodging bullets yeah in the game
yeah I had to do this yeah bishops King
c8 and here I'm promoting this thing I
want to crazy game yeah I should have
been more circumspect in the defense
it's just like here if you are precise
the game is over very quickly in
particular here after after this issue I
should just play the check at this
particular moment
I didn't didn't see that this is
happening that's a problem okay guys
thanks for watching